You know, with everything
happening in the world,
many experts are saying
people should not plan
to have a traditional
Thanksgiving celebration.
Well just today, there was
yet another press conference
from a concerned group.
We have some of the footage
of that press conference.
Have a look.
(crowd chattering)
(microphone feedback)
Thank you all for gathering here today.
Let's keep this quick.
Today I speak for all turkeys.
When I say it would be
highly inappropriate
to move forward with any
normal Thanksgiving traditions
until President Trump
has officially conceded
the presidential race.
Also no turkeys should be eaten
until everyone has
received a COVID vaccine
that is 100% effective.
It just makes sense, people.
And some are saying that
six out of eight turkeys
have contracted the death wing virus.
So thanks for coming out.
All right, let's hit that dildo store.